c'est toujours le même nerf de la guerre
en ile de france les transports reste
l'une des préoccupations majeures des
habitants dans les zones rurales plus
qu'ailleurs l'accès aux mobilité limitée
pour la majorité présidentielle et ses
têtes de listes yvelinoise l'urgence se
trouve dans l'offre de nouveaux services
il faut qu'ils aient de l'équité
territoriale on peut pas avoir une
différence de service alors qu'on paye
les mêmes impôts dans le sud yvelines
par rapport au nord des yvelines dans
les yvelines par rapport à d'autres
départements voire même plus donc on a
vraiment besoin d'avoir cette équité
territoriale gratuité des parcs relais
ça je crois que c'est vraiment un point
qui est essentiel dans le sud de notre
département et aussi les services qu'ils
soient sécurisés qui soit propre qu'il
soit bout qui donne envie en fait tout
simplement aux usagers de venir autre
priorité pour la liste menée par laurent
saint martin de la sécurité le candidat
centriste souhaite créer une police
régionale pour les lycées les transports
des domestiques est donc là il ya quatre
places mais on a encore la capacité
pouvoir développer la partie supérieure
à proximité de la gare de saint rémy les
chevreuse ce parking à vélos fermé et
protéger des infractions nous avons subi
depuis le début du confinement et même
avant cela un certain nombre d'actes
d'incivilités de cambriolage grâce à la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre de la
gendarmerie des yvelines
nous avons pu faire reculer cette
délinquance qui empoisonnait le
quotidien des commerçants de saint rémy
et nous devons rester vigilants et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous proposons
une police régionale dans les transports
qui permettra à tous les franciliens de
circuler en toute sécurité et pour les
gars de bout de ligne comme ça rémy les
chevreuse et bien de faire échec à la
délinquance transports en commun vélo
mais aussi voiture la république en
marche et ses alliés en ile de france
veulent augmenter les aides pour l'achat
de véhicules électriques
les particuliers par exemple pourrait se
voir ainsi financer jusqu'à 70% du
montant de leur nouvelle voiture